welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul in this video we're
breaking down the ending of one piece
and our thoughts for season two the new
Netflix show has a lot of things going
on with it and throughout this video
we're going to be discussing everything
that's been teased since its release
full spoilers ahead yet so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then I highly recommend that you check
out now without the way huge thank you
for clicking this now let's get into our
one-piece season 2 video
[Music]
now when the show is in development
Jamie Lee Curtis actually came out and
said that she'd love to play Dr kureha
in the live-action anime tutor her
friend Brina Palencia voicing Tony Tony
Chopper she became obsessed with the
show and on a red carpet interview at
the Oscars she said she loved to bring
Nico Robin to life though she feels
she's a bit old talking about who she
thinks she's perfect for though she said
she'd love to play Choppers meant to Dr
Correa and I think someone like this
would be such a biget for the show not
really a major season 2 prediction but
something I think we're talking about
just to kick start the video now season
one actually gave her several major
Clues and nods towards a big
organization known as Baroque works I
think this was laying the ground Baroque
works early and teasing us with who the
major antagonists in the follow-up entry
could be defeating Mr Seven after being
invited to join them Zorro clearly set
up a vendetta for what's gonna be coming
on top of this we know that gop's been
investigating them in the East blue
which will likely come to a head in the
follow-up season all of course so about
smoker in just a bit but it's important
to pay attention to these Clues before
we get into that based in the ground
line there are shadowy organization with
aims on taking the country of arabaster
for themselves now this is something
that happens throughout the arabaster
arc and I think if it doesn't appear
next time then it'll probably be the
focus of season three it's a massive
expansive piece of work and potentially
they could focus on other characters we
are teased with before dropping Baroque
Works in season three either way there
are mob who are made up of several
different devil fruit consumers working
together as one Organization for their
own political aims whereas the villains
in season 1 were largely disconnected
they operate more as an organization of
pirates at Aiden about each other now
the way that they work is that the men
in the organization are all assigned
numbers or as the women are assigned
dates and holidays so you get people
like mr5 for the men and for the women
people like Miss mundane Miss Valentine
starting off by battling Mr five the
straw hat crew work that way up the line
until they fight the organization's
leader that is crocodile who's known as
Mr zero and His companion in
leadership's Nico Robin who's known as
miss or Sunday Nico Robin was someone we
talked about before and she actually
ends up joining the straw hat crew
becoming one of its main members as for
crocodile he's extremely sought after
with him having a bounty that goes
upwards in the billions of berries
crocodile was the first character that
actually out now defeat Luffy and I
think he's probably gonna become the
main antagonist of season two sure buggy
and arvida they can provide some
challenges early on but with Luffy
already defeating them I can't see them
being season 2's major antagonists
crocodile's powers are that he wields
the abilities of the Sansan food giving
him as you guessed it the ability to
wield San personally I hate it because
it gets everywhere and his goal is
actually to steal water from the
arabaster kingdom now though I think
that will be the main Arc we of course
have smoker who pops up at the end too
if you watch Goldie Rogers execution
closely you can actually catch a couple
of characters there including me Hawks
and also Shacks smoker can be spotted in
the crowd too making me think he's gonna
be a big player in season two a smoker
gets that name not only because of his
Pawn shot for more tobacco than your
Auntie Linda you know you know the one
who who used to used to go around on a
Saturday morning and watch a smoke 60 a
day before she said come here love give
us a kiss but but also because of his
devil fruit abilities a smoker is a
smoker is able to Tin himself in a smoke
and this makes him an extremely powerful
character the reason that he's burning
up the wanted poster has a double layer
to it too as the character isn't
actually a pirate smoker is a marine
with an obsession for hunting them and
this also seems to set up where we'll be
heading in season two smoker is the boss
of the Marine base in log town and this
is also the last stop before you get to
the ground Line blog town was where
Goldie Rogers was executed and unless I
think they'll be heading there at the
start of the next entry now it is
possible out we might see a return of
our long if they decided if the things
from the Manga and Anime in that though
our long hasn't returned physically it's
been confirmed that he didn't die
fighting Luffy the character is
definitely one of the standards of
season one and they'll bring him back
wouldn't be in line with the source
material I think it would be an
interesting addition to have him return
in some way we now have Nami getting her
new tattoo and I think the history
between the pair could still provide a
pretty interesting Dynamic it's better
the devil fruit you know and him being a
reoccurring villain could set the show
apart from its source material though
that doesn't always work out now we know
for definite who will be returning and
that is of course Boogie and alvida the
latter actually becomes a big player on
Buggy's crew and I can see the scorn
antagonists working together to try and
take down the straw hat crew in the
second season the pair both appear in
the log Town Arc with Captain smoker and
it makes sense that they're going to be
major people that we see coming back
next time there's also me Hawks and
Shanks he'll be returning to and the
first season ends with them meeting up
with one another drinking to Luffy
getting his first Bounty I imagine we'll
be seeing me Hawk's relationship with
more of the Pirates in season 2. this
scene plays out exactly the same way as
it does in the anime but they could
easily build in their relationship
leading up to the big battle in the time
Jump what this does show though is that
there's a sort of sort of respect
between the Pirates and Warlords and we
know this also extends to the Marines as
well sort of like when a YouTuber asks
someone to like And subscribe and they
do it because they've watched most of
the video up until this point and it
would be the honorable thing to do now
one of the major characters who could
also turn up his Ace who's the
biological son of Goldie Roger as
mentioned in our inning explained
garpa's ass by Goldie Roger to look
after his son and eventually go up ended
up arranging for Luffy and Ace to live
together as non-biological Brothers
alongside a character named Sabo Ace was
also someone if he looked up to and he
joined the Whitebeard Pirates eventually
making it his aim in life to take out
Blackbeard Blackbeard was a pirate who
turned Rogue against Whitebeard as he
killed a crew member just to get their
devil fruit he appears every so often
and made his debut during The arabaster
Saga so looking at everything for season
two it would make a lot of sense a huge
announce to our friends are at the
streamer who got to interview the
creative team and talk about the series
not only did they handle exploring love
town next time but they also talked
about some of the things they had in
place for Baroque works when discussing
teasers they actually talked about how
some of the musical themes had been a
little hint to them as well Sonia
belasova said we do have a theme for
Baroque Works which is that secret
organization that we're going to explore
hopefully in further Seasons when inep
when in episode 1 there's a fight
between Zoro and Mr Seven Mr Seven is
the part of that organization he shows
Zorro his card that's where you are that
scene so it's the same theme for Baroque
works I represent an organization known
as Baroque works we are interested in
your unique set of skills it's a really
interesting way to tease it and expect
to hear that a lot more in the future
anyway that wraps up my main season 2
predictions and for the rest of the
video I wanted to talk about where we
might see things going in terms of
release date you never know what's going
to happen with Netflix when it comes to
canceling but so far the show seems
pretty popular I don't have exact
figures yet but yesterday when I saw
trending it had about 70 000 tweets on
just a Netflix hashtag alone so it's
safe to say that people are talking
about it the reviews are really good too
and with lots of interest in this
adaptation from a-listers like Jamie Lee
Curtis I can't see things being put into
production pretty early on unfortunately
that doesn't mean we'll get a season
next year as everything's getting
delayed at the moment due to the big
strikes in Hollywood until that gets
negotiated there's not going to be any
progress made on a follow-up and if I'm
being honest I wouldn't hold your breath
for it now coming soon.net have stated
the earliest we can expect season 2 is
2025 and even then it might be the mid
to latter part of the air so yeah a bit
of a bummer with everything that's going
on but luckily they've got the source
material that they can pull from because
of this I don't think the writing will
be as intense as they have a brief
outline of where things need to go I'm
not sure about all the writing that goes
into an adaptation but I can imagine
that it's at least quicker rather than
you coming up with ideas yourself and
then scrapping them because they don't
work now 2025 seems like a long way away
and if you're dying to know what happens
yeah you've always got the Manga and
Anime that's still ongoing to this day
and there's so much to pull from when it
comes to that of course saying that
Kirby and God will be back too and we've
got these really interesting characters
developing on all sides you've got the
Marines the Pirates and Baroque Works
leading to a big season that Kirby
coming next time and of course love to
hear your thoughts on where you think
it's gonna go and what you'd like to see
in the a second season if they don't
call a two-piece we Riot yeah imagine if
they call that but please drop a like on
the video and if you want to support the
channel as a member of this spoiler
Society then please click the join
button you'll get early access to videos
every week and it goes such a long way
to helping us out you want to get some
heavy spoilers merch we've also got our
t-shirt line located below the video
that will let you pick up Top Cycle
Theory time one house the dragon stuff
Marvel teas and more we dropped new
designs on there all the time so
definitely keep an eye out for them and
yeah it really helps to help us out if
you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our ending
explain breakdown and review which will
be linked on screen right now to talk
about all the show in depth and I I had
such a good time with it that I hope you
guys join me over there to hear me
ramble about it more huge thank you for
thanks to the video as always I've been
your host Paul and I hope to see you
guys on the next video you take care of
yourself peace
thank you